From damming rivers to changing the chemistry
of the atmosphere, humans have had a powerful
impact on our planet. But what would happen
if we suddenly disappeared?
The first few weeks would be chaotic. Within
hours, power plants would run out of fuel
and shut down. As lights go out and electric
fences lose their sting, over one and a half
billion cows, nearly a billion pigs and more
than 20 billion chickens will break out of
their enclosures, desperate for food. Without
any humans to feed them, most of these livestock
will starve or become food for over half a
billion dogs and a roughly equal number of
cats who now have to fend for themselves.
Of course, many of our fancy breeds are ill-suited
for life in the wild, and will probably be
outcompeted by hardier mutts, not to mention
wolves, coyotes and wildcats. Other animals
that depend on humans, from rats to cockroaches,
will suffer drastic population declines. Some,
like body lice and head lice, will go extinct.
In the cities, many of our famous boulevards
are now rivers. Without electric pumps to
keep
them dry, underground subway tunnels will
quickly fill with water. Other streets will
be overtaken with weeds and vines, followed
by larger plants and trees.
But before that happens, most cities will
be wiped out by fire. Modern houses, especially
in the suburbs, are still largely made of
timber. With no firefighters around, a single
lightning strike is all it takes to start
a fire that could burn whole subdivisions
to the ground. In the countryside, many wood
structures will be destroyed within a few
decades, if not by fire, then by termites
and other decomposers.
After 100 years most wood structures will
be gone, and anything made of steel - from
apartment
buildings to cars and even bridges - aren’t
far behind. Steel is mostly iron, and without
constant
application of paints and coatings, it will
quickly react with oxygen in the atmosphere
and return to its native form of iron oxide,
or rust.
By this time humans have been gone for a few
hundred years, and most species of animals
around the world - at least, the ones we haven’t
driven to extinction - will have bounced back
to
the levels they were at before we evolved.
But their distribution will remain forever
altered.
Camels now roam Australia, while in North
America dozens of species of songbirds imported
from Europe will continue to thrive. It’s
even possible that in some parts of the world,
escaped zoo animals could form new wild populations,
leading to the prospect of lions on the Great
Plains, or hippos in South American rivers.
Forever proliferating through space will be
the electromagnetic radiation we created from
our radios, satellites and phones.
But if anything will outlast us on Earth,
it may be our trash. The chemical bonds that
hold together plastics or vulcanized rubber
are immune to most of the digestive enzymes
used by bacteria to break down natural polymers
and unlike metals, plastics don’t rust or
corrode. These microplastics escape into waterways
or drift along in the ocean and are eventually
deposited in sediments. Hundreds of millions
of years from now, alien geologists from outer
space may be surprised to find sedimentary
rocks full of tiny carbon-based particles
that were once part of rubber tires or plastic
bags.
Of course, whether something survives depends
greatly on the conditions. Everything will
last
much longer in deserts, where there is no
moisture to speed up rusting or support decomposing
organisms. And while the carbon cycle will
return CO2 levels to equilibrium after a few
thousand years, local deposits of long-lived
organic chemicals or radioactive material
could persist for a very, very long time.
It’s hard to know what alien paleontologists
of the future will make of us; how they will
explain
our love of plastic or the fact that within
a geological eyeblink we exploded out of Africa
to
colonize virtually every inhabitable space
on earth. But they’ll definitely wonder
why, if we
were so successful for so long, we disappeared
so quickly.
This episode is brought to you by Squarespace.com.
If you’ve ever wanted to make your own website,
Squarespace recently launched the latest version
of their platform, Squarespace 7, which has
a completely redesigned interface, integrations
with Getty Images and Google Apps, new templates,
and an incredible feature called Cover Pages.
You can start your free trial at Squarespace.com/asap
and if you decide to sign up, use the offer
code ASAP at checkout to get 10% off. Thanks
again to squarespace for supporting our show.
And if you haven’t seen our latest AsapTHOUGHT
video on Why We Mishear Lyrics, you can check
that out with a link in the description as
well - it should give you a good laugh and
hopefully help solve some mysteries of your
brain on music.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!